right now everyone's saying like could
you imagine if we had to get like some
kind of tattoo to track us bro I know it
sounds bad but let me tell you something
two generations nobody would care yeah
you'd be born with tattoo and you'd get
it updated every couple years and people
would be like oh make sure to scan your
barcode when you're you know entering
the building yeah like we have we have
ID cards passports social security
numbers well know of all of these how
about like a was a movie Minority Report
where they walk into the subway and they
look at the scanner it's like Boop gets
their eyes that iris is Boop welcome
John Anderton they've figured out a way
around that it's called a cell phone so
basically the way it works now they know
everything and everywhere you go dude
Facebook knows Eris's Facebook knows on
your food yes but I'm not even don't
have facebook on my phone it doesn't
matter how did they know them Wow
Facebook's not on my phone I never got
it so whoa it doesn't matter how do they
have access to anything does anyone in
your family have Facebook probably boom
done how would they know when I poop
though when you tell you give me the
logic when you text and communicate wait
I don't communicate with others with
your family no never
yes you do so here's how so Facebook has
a thing called shadow profiles so you
have a Facebook profile okay you also
have a shadow profile and Facebook
accidentally released this one day like
a glitch on accident yeah oh and people
saw their shadow profiles it's got crazy
stuff in there they know Facebook can
predict what you will eat that sounds
like Westworld more see Wow now I would
be spoiling so I'm not gonna say
anything but man is what people need to
realize oh man let's say you don't have
a Facebook account you do have a
Facebook profile let's say you know no
Tim I've never signed up for Facebook
you still have a Facebook profile it's
very simple yeah profile right yeah with
all your profile do with all your
information right mmm so check this out
your mom your dad your brother your
sister your girlfriend whatever they all
have you saved in their phones as Adam
son boyfriend husband whatever right
mm-hmm when they download the Facebook
app which is by default on Android
phones and can't be deleted
seriously yeah oh geez so
you have an Android no no you're lucky
you might still have Facebook on it so
what happens is when they open the
messenger it says would you like to sync
your contacts Facebook gets access to
all of the contact list of everyone who
knows you
and then here's they find out they know
who your mom is they know here your
significant other as who your best
friend is they can tell based on the
frequency of like messages and things
like that now if you actually use the
apps yeah that's when they can really
predict your behavior
I want someone's email at Facebook so I
can email them when I'm actually pooping
be like hey Facebook I'm pooping just
see you have no you understand you're
gonna you're gonna draft the email and
you're gonna back all [ __ ] I'll show
them and then your phone's gonna go burn
you know wait what and it's gonna be
like we know Adam you don't know I'm not
kidding I'm not kidding before you
attend so I was reading this crazy thing
is separating basically they know where
people will eat and what time they will
eat because they can start predicting
based on when your break time is so
here's what they know well from the
hours of 855 until 11:30 for your phone
doesn't move mm-hmm then it travels
three blocks you know North to a
shopping center for you know 15 minutes
comes back and then stops moving again
guess what hmm they know it's most
likely your lunch break and you want to
go eat so they also know based on the
things you say and what time it is when
you're going to go to eat and where you
will likely eat when I tell you there
was a this test thing that they had a
long time ago I think was called like
the spark or something was a website
okay and they created these tests where
they could predict things about you
where would be like we can we can prove
whether or not you're like a man or a
woman or whether you're white or not
white and they would ask you questions
that seemingly made no sense
it would be like which would you prefer
and then I would show you weird shapes
you'd be like no when you click one
right okay and then at the end they
would tell you for some reason
white men click this shape and white
women click that shape hmm we don't know
why I want to take this test it's old so
it's from like it's like 90s man's like
late 90s yeah research if I compare but
there is all there there still is a lot
of stuff like that like Jonathan Heights
research okay which does like a moral
moral
like moral foundations testing and stuff
like that so you can see you like where
you are politically do you believe in
Liberty and stuff is that the one I did
like a couple no that was a political
compass test oh yeah but anyway the main
point is Facebook can predict when you
will poop based on when you eat when
they send that info to think about it I
think they're doing all right in this
Bend oh boy
listen toilet paper advertiser says we
want to maximize sales yeah facebook
says we know when to show your ad for
maximum effect think about it like Oh
Facebook Instagram like oh yeah here
yeah definitely during these times more
people poop and then get an audience
again it'll be like scratchy bum you
need double quilted bro what are you
doing well you're gonna be like dude for
real you know I have bought happen but I
have bought a ton of stuff off of
Instagram - Oh paper not toilet paper
this lamp this lamp yep they knew wasn't
the arrival London wasn't the original
one from Instagram - this one dari night
one no no the original the starry night
oh no no that was a friend of mine
alright was like over there somewhere
you got that over here yeah you can't
see it in any of the shots though
unfortunately it's little it's tiny
teeny tiny so think about what all of
these other networks know Google Google
probably knows a lot too and yeah and
people don't realize like we talked
about like we can't let them you know
chip us all right it's like bro you
bought your chip yeah you you you know
great you were like bro upgrade my chip
please you know it's funny I was
listening to Rogen and they were talking
about this conspiracy theory and I
really do mean it where they where
people think their phones are listening
to them they aren't they no no they're
not
it's just well it's it depends right so
there's actually some truth to this
smart devices always have the
microphones on okay because they have
voice activation oh right so they are
listening to you but when Facebook
delivers an ad to you and you were
talking about it it's not because they
were listening to you it's because they
know everything about you and can
predict your behavior yeah it's worse
than you realize way worse that is worse
I remember
I went to Walmart mm-hmm made a sale on
TVs and we were walking through the
aisle and the TVs were in the middle of
the aisle look on reat and discount or
whatever and it was a big TV and I was
like that's good it was 300 bucks and
I'm like it's a widescreen TV like we
don't we don't have a TV like TV broke
I'll grab it so we call the guy over he
puts in the cart when I got home I went
on Facebook and there was an ad showing
what appeared to be that exact same TV
on the stand in the middle and I was
like what's going on this is crazy
interesting but it wasn't because they
were listening to me mm-hmm it was
because they knew I went to Walmart they
knew that I was you know a 32 year old
male yup they so they predicted I would
probably you know want this TV mm-hmm
right Wow you're the most annoying thing
about all that is though no I don't why
don't you tell me you ever get an
advertisement or something you already
bought yep like you just explained it
but right but like even worse like you
go to Amazon and you'll be like I need
some you know double quilted TP bro and
then you buy it and then also you go to
a website you see all these ads for
double quilted you're like dude I
already ordered it why are you
advertising this to me
okay something like toilet paper you
keep getting yeah but like right app
okay forget toilet paper let's say let's
say you order a fancy new I think the
TiVo will summed it up right there well
protec deck oh wait so you get the fancy
tech deck with the fancy little or those
pro this this is the I just put the grip
tape on a regular one because I don't I
don't like yeah these are the pro ones
these are like we had to build these
although you said that they're not that
good I don't like it I mean I don't know
not this one specifically there's
there's better ones it's pretty legit
though that's what it is but the pop is
bad I mean I don't know how to even pop
these things
yeah no they're good fun all right but I
ordered some better ones with better
grip with with bigger noses and Tails
anyway the point is I bought it already
I don't need anymore I've got it look
it's a tech deck where all-time tech
it's a finger board why are they
advertising them to me I go on because
you're not happy with those you know
it's funny you said all right you said
they don't have enough pop you want
something better maybe they know thing
well they're advertising ones I don't
want oh okay that's a point I'll let
everybody in on a secret when you're
watching my videos look at the
advertisements when I'm reading news
stories uh-huh and you'll know what
we're doing so there's been a few videos
where it's like the ads are for
be an agent for camera equipment and
tripods circa it's because we're talking
up the new show yeah yeah it's a
screenshot of one of your videos one
time and I was like look what Tim has
for his ads he has skateboards he has
skate shoes and he had I forget what it
was you had almost like beanies or
something skate ramps was was on there
for a while we were doing like mints and
I kept seeing that the dance lock that
you ordered and I like you what you know
where I was just skating that earlier
and then and then if those are listening
if you're watching watching what the ads
are you can then like comment be like
how's the new the new skate box Tim well
I mean is it an ad for something that
you already got or something that you're
probably gonna buy so there's a company
and all there's two companies there is
OSI ramps and there's Keene ramps and I
think I'm pretty sure the mini ramp we
have is keen
yeah so good that's a good really good
and so I just ordered another smaller
one for a like practice from Keene also
yes nice I'm pretty sure it is I seen
that little ramp actually they did a
giveaway like a week ago or so on
Instagram yeah yeah the lock downs
jamming up delivery but yeah when you
see the ads it'll be an ad for the whole
company so you'll see a grind rail you
won't know exactly what it is that I
bought yeah but I think it's really
funny because I was looking at the price
of gold and silver once mhm and then all
of a sudden all the ads were for gold
and silver and I'm like I wonder I
wonder if people gonna catch this you
know I've actually thought that multiple
times and not one person has has asked
us like hey about about the ads it feels
like people are well thankfully they're
probably listening to what we're talking
about you might well I think I think a
lot of people are just listening to yeah
like well they're doing stuff that makes
so so well actually let me ask you guys
good thing or bad thing what that
shooters know what you want before you
even know what you want well I mean I
don't want to see ads for I can't you
already bought think of random things
that I would never buy or never even I
don't know it's it's a good thing is a
bad thing it's just a thing
III what do you think I think it tends
to be based on whatever you're looking
at it could be good or bad
my question is if you were sitting here
one day and the NAD popped up for like
this UFO thing and you're like I want
that mm-hmm
would you be happy when you bought it
like I bought that I saw an ad on
Instagram and I was like I would like to
buy that a full disclosure I do that all
the time so it's a good thing yeah works
for me I don't know every single time
anyone is ever - I've never bought
anything off of Instagram in fact when
Facebook first bought Instagram the ads
were just insane and I would report
every single ad forming trash so the
point of I would go on Instagram to
block ads and I was like what am I even
doing on Instagram and I kind of stopped
instagramming for a while but now it's
to the point where anyone's like oh yeah
I got this thing on Instagram and I just
all I could think is just there's a
little like giggle like sucker yeah half
the stuff is made in China half of its
POS is I mean actually more way more
than half there's a lot of it that I'm
just like that's just gonna be trash one
day I bet this is made chef I mean sure
that UFO is has we've had a lot of fun
on the show with the UFO when it's not
spinning everyone starts like spin the
UFO it's been great it's part it's part
of the show so for us it does make sense
there you go spin that UFO Wow it is
really but I still I still when you
first told me where you got it I called
you a sucker in my head for buying for
Instagram yep awesome it's levitating
loading yeah sure it's cool that's cool
yeah cool
anti-gravity man great it's a bad thing
when they're advertising things you
already bought that's stupid
but think about think about this like
okay so we often project our current
technology the future yeah okay so
instead of thinking about what we can't
we can't predict for the most part so we
take things we already have any we
exaggerate them right so a good example
is Back to the Future right he goes to
the Future it's 20 was it 2015 yeah and
his shoes tied themselves yeah or
whatever in his like clothes shrank it's
like it's an exaggeration of what
already existed there's a really funny
graphic that I remember seeing once
where it was like in the year 1900 what
they thought the
mm would be like and it was firefighters
with mechanical wings flying like
because it was technology they had but
they were like what if it was better so
we can't make that same mistake so you
know I'm thinking about what's the
logical conclusion of these weird AI
advertisement stuff and the assumption
is we live in a world where before you
even think you want it it's delivered to
you like you're sitting there and you're
like man I'm hungry like before you even
say you want it's like eggs just like
you know a robot comes in and drops eggs
a certain amount of time so you're
probably gonna be hungry no plate just
drop it right on the table
oh no no no served up right for you it's
like your chair brings you to the
bathroom before even though you have to
go and you're like I don't have to oh
the turtles be set out and then
eventually we're just like we're just
like we don't move we're sitting in
chairs like exactly that's scary but I
don't think so I don't think so I don't
think so because that's projecting right
yeah it is thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you